Speaker 1: This is absolutely fascinating. The
amount of potential criminality that radical,
repugnant Republican Congressman Madison
Cawthorn has been engaged in is very high.
We talked yesterday about him bringing a knife to
a school board meeting and now being caught with
guns twice at airports. The latest is that
Madison Cawthorn appears to be implicated
in an insider trading scheme and also may
have violated the STOCK Act by failing to
disclose a Let's Go Brandon cryptocurrency
purchase. Now we're going to go through the
details of the two stories in a moment, but it
can't be ignored that there very clearly seems
to be a concerted effort from the right to damage
Madison. Cawthorn. Cawthorn, a few weeks ago made
headlines by saying he'd been invited to cocaine
fueled orgies by fellow members of Congress. The
Republican Party didn't like that. It potentially
is true. Either way, it doesn't matter. They seem
to now be targeting Madison Cawthorn and the the
targeting is being done by Republicans. So let's
start first with an article in The Washington
Examiner. This is a right wing publication,
Madison Cawthorn implicated in potential
insider trading scheme, experts say. Madison,
Cawthorn may have violated federal insider trading
laws as he hyped up an alleged pump and dump
cryptocurrency scheme. Multiple watchdog groups
told The Washington Examiner. On December 29th,
the beleaguered North Carolina congressman posed
at a party with James Catullus, a hedge fund
manager and the ringleader of the Let's Go Brand
in Cryptocurrency, a meme coin set up in the wake
of the chant Mocking Joe Biden. Cawthorn posted
on Instagram. Let's go, Brandon Legends. Tomorrow
we go to the moon. The next day, LG Bitcoin
went bonkers and the value spiked by 75%.
Multiple watchdog groups told The Washington
Examiner that The Post suggests he may have
had advanced nonpublic knowledge of LG Bitcoins
deal. The watchdog said the Post, combined with
his statement that he owns the coin. Warrant an
investigation. This looks really, really bad,
said the government affairs manager for Project
on Government Oversight. Similarly. He may have
violated what's called the STOCK Act. Remember,
insider trading trading and the Stock Act are two
different things. They are related often when
it comes to members of Congress. The STOCK Act
applies specifically to members of Congress.
Insider trading laws apply more generally to
everybody, but as a member of Congress, he
may have access to particular information.
So there are two stories here. There's the story
itself about Madison, Cawthorn insider trading,
violating the Stock Act, bringing guns to
airports, all of these legal issues. And the
general question as to whether he's going to be
held accountable for any of it. Now, of course,
everybody's innocent until proven guilty. My
position, unlike the people who go lock her up,
lock up, Hillary. Wait a second. Hillary hasn't
been charged and she hasn't been found guilty.
You can't lock her up. So I don't say lock up,
Madison Cawthorn. I say there certainly is smoke
here. So there should be an investigation and the
investigation should take us where it will. And on
that basis, if he committed crimes, he should
be charged. He shouldn't be exempt from being
charged because if he's a member of Congress, the
political story that is very interesting is the
obviously concerted effort by the Republican Party
to oust Madison. CAWTHORN When the Washington
Examiner is publishing dirt on a conservative on
a Republican, I shouldn't call him a conservative
on a neo reactionary Republican. It may be a
signal that the establishment Republican Party
is done with him, and every indication is that the
cocaine fueled orgy story is what sort of put this
over the edge and we'll see what Madison
Cawthorn future holds. I don't know the
answer, but at minimum right now there is
plenty of smoke telling us there should be
numerous criminal investigations going on.
We'll follow it. We'll see where it goes